are you ready
okay
good afternoon everyone welcome to this
meeting of David District Council
cabinet I'm councilor John Ward leader
of baby District Council and I'll be
chairing this meeting
may I remind you of some domestic
Arrangements please ensure that
microphones are turned off when not in
use
please do not interrupt other speakers
or hold separate conversations whilst
others are speaking
if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting you may be asked to leave
please ensure your mobile phones are on
silent or Switched Off
and finally we will be using e-voting
for this meeting on the modern.gov app
so please give members make sure that
they are logged in and ready to use the
app
I would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing the whole of the
meeting will be filmed except whether
our confidential or exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you'll be deemed by the council
to have consented to being filmed
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council and to the
possible use of those images and sound
recordings for webcasting and or
training purposes
the council members of the public and
the Press May record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and the Press are not lawfully excluded
I'll now move to the agenda item one
apologies for absence
thank you item two to receive
Declarations of pecunery other
registerable or non-registerable
interest by members are there any
nope thank you
item three paper BCA 2238 to confirm the
minutes of the meeting held on 9th of
January 2023 and you'll find the meeting
minutes on pages 5 to 13 of the agenda
pack I just go through these and please
let me know if there are any points you
wish to make page five
Page Six
Council Busby
83.5 just for clarity
uh apparently I queried whether other
working adults were expected to
contribute I think it ought to be other
working adults in the same household
thank you
page seven
page eight
page nine
page 10.
page 11.
page 12.
and finally page 13.
so if there are no other points to raise
may have a proposal please
Council McLaren and a seconder
councilman VC
and we'll now go to the vote please
thank you chair that vote is now in
progress councilman crawl
may I take you about
um
in favor thank you very much Council
thank you chair that's seven votes for
that's unanimous thank you item four to
receive notification of petitions in
accordance with the council's petition
scheme
item five questions by councilors
non-received
thank you and item six matters referred
by the overview scrutiny or joint order
at the standards committees
standard
thank you committee
item seven forthcoming decisions lists
members of the cabinet does anyone have
any comments on the forthcoming
decisions list
no
okay then we'll move on to the next item
item eight paper BCA 2239 the general
fund budget for 2023-24 and four-year
Outlook I'll now invite the cabinet
member for finance assets Investments to
introduce the support councilor Busby
okay we've been through this a few times
so I'll try a different approach this
afternoon
I've been in finance for 50 years I
started with Ford Motor Company on 164
pounds per year
many of you will be earning more than
that per week
I've never experienced such a crazy
budgeting scenario that faces us today
net service expenditure is up 19 2.4
million and interest charges up from
zero to four percent another 1.2 million
the fund list the government restricts
our grants increase to less than six
percent and only allows an increase in
council tax of under three percent
it is no wonder that we were looking at
a shortfall of two million pounds
but at the 11th Hour the government
announces that it will fund us for the
potential loss of a million pound on
business rates and we managed to find
through savings and the use of reserves
the balance
however whilst I can present a balanced
budget fee today we are still facing
considerable Financial challenges going
forward
may seem strange to some that two
councils who share the same staff the
same building and largely the same
objectives and policies can have such
wildly different Financial positions
the main answer is uh extra 6.6 million
pounds of new homes bonus amid Suffolk
over the 12 years it has been operating
mid Suffolk has received 18.4 million
compared to baber's 11.8
is it right that a council's finances
are governed by Developers
that they want to build out
something needs to change but in the
meantime I move the recommendation in
three and ask for a second
thank you Castle Busby that was a very
interesting introduction and
um to say I couldn't disagree with any
of that
may I have a second of these
councilman craw
L right members of the cabinet do you
have any questions on the budget
councilman McLaren
um when we have a problem we call in
experts as we don't have the required
skills in-house and we also pay for
external services on a regular basis
do we have the details of these payments
um itemized in the budget
so that's two parts one is the short
term and the other is the sort of like
the Auditors are external contracts
aren't they
but we have we have the individual
amounts
yes but they're not broken out into in
this budget is that possible to
I'd be interested to see
um those figures if they're available
I'm looking at my experts that are
in-house
difficult counselor must be sitting
behind me
I was on about the different extra
staff hours that we we have external
contractors that are routine like
Auditors that we pay for but we also
when we have a problem we often call in
experts
and I just wondered if we had some
details of that that expenditure I did
look for it but I couldn't find it
and we don't put that level of detail in
here or even in the budget book to be
fair but I'm happy to share that with
you outside of the meeting especially
the ones where experts are called and
where we have yeah we do monitor that
ourselves at SLT as well so I'm happy to
to share that with you thanks Melissa
thank you chair
all right any other questions from
members of the cabinet
Council McLaren
um at what point are we going to get the
see the benefit of the solar panels in
Hungary no Kingfisher Leisure Center
sorry
because there is a benefit benefit to
Abbey craft pleasure but will we get
some report on that
I'm not certain way to get something on
the individual amount when you're
getting the benefits already
across electricity down
I'm sure we can ask Abby Croft for for
these
just
as a as a Cabinet member
but it's um actually paying dividends
thank you thank you yes we should be
asking you that question Linda yeah well
I don't know it yet
okay
councilor malvisi
Chad
[Music]
it's a bit like a recipe it's got Grid
electricity it's got solar panels on its
own roof it's got solar panels on the
solar carports which are primarily there
to provide electric vehicle charging
points
the Surplus goes into a battery store
like the solar panels on the roof and
they power up
the Leisure Center
we've reduced the cost of no we've aimed
at reducing the cost of um
the overall Energy bill
by installing the filt filtration system
on the swimming pool which means that
the water is heated to a certain level
it's then put through a filtration
system and it doesn't lose much of its
heat in that process so all these
elements
um have not had a chance to function for
a 12-month period to give us the
necessary data to be able to move
forward on the next step but the
electricity that Kingfisher uses we move
them to a green energy tariff which is
one of the lowest
it's helpful because actually those are
the sort of questions the public ask
yeah okay okay thank you thank you
councilman crawl
thank you chair
um I'd like to ask the cabinet member
for something you referred to obliquely
in his introduction which is actually
Forefront in my mind
which is the projected deficits in
forthcoming years and and I wonder if he
can provide any information for
residents voters because
on
how we might be able to deal with those
projected deficits and and of course the
and how big that shortfall might be
blocking the paper
um shows how that deficit builds up over
the next two or three years at this
stage we we haven't got specific
plans to deal with that
um that'll be one of our first
challenges in the new Financial year
and as I as I mentioned in my room
report introduction
it's very difficult to do these budgets
because most of the important
information the government won't give us
until the last last minute of of the
year like every year a huge amount of
uncertainty thanks
any other questions
case I'll before we go to debate I'll
ask other members present if they have
any questions starting with the chair of
overview and scrutiny would do you have
any questions just just a quick on Mr
chairman I was just looking at page 22
of the report we showed PV panels of
giving an income of 370 000.
the houses rather than the ones on the
solar panels
but I'm not sure how many panels there
are on the Kingfisher Leisure Etc that
and it also depends a little bit on
which way they point
and whether they're going to get shaded
Etc but there is considerable income
coming from those other solar panels
added to which of course that is the
income but of course the householders
get to use the electricity as well so
there's a reduction in their individual
bills so the actual amount earned is
probably considerably more
thank you any councilor Barrett uh Simon
Barrett then Melanie Barrett
yours went up first oh did it yeah
um just a question on the brutal balance
uh in the uh general fund of 527
000.
which was brought forward
um how does that square with the out
turn of 1.4 million where is the
difference gone
Council Busby
well I think five two five hundred
twenty thousand you referred to as the
projected Surplus
in the budget is that what you're
referring to yeah basically if you look
at the um
you've got 524 was a brought forward
so in your
comms where you've got your pressures
and your other bits you've got your 525
as a brought for balance
okay so that's obviously a figure that
came forward but the out turn statement
that we had last year was 1.4 million
now presumably
was John was 1.4 million out turn that
was the outturn for 21-22
uh 22 22 23 art term will come in this
summer so 21-22 right 22. so you've got
that as you're out turn tape for that
which has obviously come forward
that would then indicate that the so the
position that we're in now so are you
saying that that
hasn't come forward again or was that
all absorbed within the reserve budgets
that it was allocated to within the last
last year 20 22-23
um so of the 1.4 million half a million
pounds of that we put into the
inflationary pressures Reserve
so that's gone into this current Year's
reserves and I think from Quarter Two I
think from memory we're forecasting
about an 800k deficit so we'll be using
that half a million pounds to cover that
plus some money from your strategic
priorities Reserve as well you're 527
000 that you're seeing here is this
current years
forecast Surplus
so that's only a forecast anyway yeah
and we're forecasting a deficit of 800
. I'm pretty
it was the budget it was the budgeted
Surplus and the latest Q2 had about an
actual figure so um right okay we'll
need to wait until this Summer's out and
Yeah well I just thought with the 1.4 we
had in the 2020 122 it would have been a
bit more brought forward but clearly
that was if you've got the deficits
coming yeah I can see all right
can see where we are on that one
um
the other point if I have another one
on the reduced
Reserve go down from 1.2 to 1 million
you've kept that Reserve at 1 million
uh did you then continue to keep the
extra 200 000 into the grants
or did you reduce the grants
because originally the 200k went into
the Grant and the previous year
thank you
spent hasn't it I think yeah so we put
that into the year marked reserve and
that has been used on community grants
so that was a one-off yeah no that was
just a one-off funding year that got
spent
councilor Melanie Barrett
thank you chair um I'd like to make a
request
um on how the budget is presented to
councilors and I think it was time to do
that this year because it's quite simple
Edition
um this is prompted by this year's
significant increase in staff course the
whopping 1.9 million
um but it's an idea I've been growing on
for a while
so what
I really like you to consider is if um
staff costs could be shown
as a percentage of counts staff course
as a percentage of council income
so as you can see it's quite a a simple
a simple addition or and perhaps also as
as a percentage of overall expenditure
so those two elements and then I believe
that that will allow an informed
analysis year on year for councilors to
see whether this figure goes up or down
or stays static as as you might expect
so your question is asking us if we can
do that yes
um I think we probably have to take it
away and think about that but Melissa I
don't know if you've got an immediate
answer yeah
Clarity really I just wondered if chart
4 on page 21 gives you what you need I
know we haven't got the percentage in
there of employees as a course but it's
showing us the the green chunk so that's
chart four on page 21. shows our
employee costs as a whole
against the expenditure or whether you
wanted some more
straight away and identify whether it's
consistent with last year the year
before
um because it would depend which figure
for expenditure to use and I know
perhaps talking to Catherine Steele in
previous years that figure that you
could arrive at that figure in different
ways so for the consistency I think it's
safer if we as cancers are presented
with it as a percentage and this also
does get over the fact that you might
have contracted in or out staff in any
year so just looking at staff figures is
not a an indicator in itself
and you've got to look at it relative to
to the overall income
um
I think you've hit the nail on the head
there the problem is that we have
contracted out staff in the past
our public realm which have now come in
so if you compend one year before with
another event the increase would seems
very significant because of the bringing
that staff in-house
um I guess it's a possibility I think
would hopefully if we don't change any
of our structure in terms of Outsourcing
or having
just looking at this the the chart that
um has been referred to chart four does
show the employee costs uh against the
total expenditure and uh obviously you
can see that the 11.6 million is
um just over 50 of the 22.7 million so
um uh that's it in terms of um the
employee proportion of expenditure costs
but against income
um do you mean just income what do you
mean income and funding together because
our income from uh
various fees and servicing companies is
just 10.2 million as you'll see in chart
five
to follow that so that for comparative
purposes it's a meaningful comparison if
compared to other councils okay well
we'll we'll take it on board and have a
look but um I I think the information
that's presented here is is quite clear
as it stands but we'll then take another
look and uh and see if anything more can
be done thank you the problem is John
it's only one year yeah it doesn't it
doesn't show us with learner
okay
are there any other questions
just before we go back to councilor
Osborne from this uh no other questions
from other members okay Council Osborne
is this question are you heading to
debate just to come back on that
in homelessness a lot of that is
prevention so how do you demonstrate
that in terms of Revenue when you've
prevented homelessness but also if we
again if we go down that route and we do
show it differently can we also show
those posts then that are funded by
central government and not just by go to
District Council because I think that's
also very important there's a lot of
posts in housing that are government
funded so do not reflect in this figure
at all thank you Mr chairman okay right
um so members of the cabinet we've heard
questions we're now moving to debate
does anyone wish to contribute anything
to the debate on on this budget paper
councilor Osborne
it was this really scary position that
we saw ourselves in and we looked at it
and we were thinking gosh are we going
to actually have to cut Services we've
come up with a fantastic budget I think
that enables us to not cut back on
Services which is really important to
our residents and our communities so to
the officers I'm thankful for that and
to councilor Busby's putting a lot of
time as well so I'm glad we've come up
with this budget
um I think though however we mustn't be
complacent because we keep performing
Miracles really as far as our budget's
concerned and we can't keep doing that
so we really need to start thinking on
our feet for next year where we're going
to go to make sure that we continue with
a balanced budget without cutting back
Services because that is critical thank
you Mr chairman yeah thank you Council
Oswald
um yeah and obviously with this year
we've seen as Council Busby has as uh
said earlier
um a 19 increase in our total net cost
of service
um despite the the savings that we've
looked for and been able to make um
there's still that gap between
um the pressures and savings which are
described in in the paper here
um and and yes I'm listening to the team
have done brilliantly and but we've also
must remember that we have been uh
compensated by government to significant
amount on on business rates
um I know other Government funding
hasn't been that that great but the the
business rates um
uh income that we're getting uh funding
that we're getting is is significant and
we can't always guarantee that year on
you um and and without that and I think
that's about eight hundred thousand
isn't it Melissa something like that
um so
that's a huge amount and if if we were
to lose that in future years then then
clearly we're going to have to give
significant problems
and um uh uh it's not like everything we
we've got to every year we've got to
really think about this and think about
particularly on on fees and income
um how we can generate more money
ourselves because we can't rely on on
funding we can't rely on government
grants we can't rely on business rates
and we certainly can't rely on council
tax because we are
um very limited as Council of us as we
said
in terms of what we can do 2.99 is the
maximum we can do
um and we're in a period where we've got
um inflation of in excess of 10 percent
so we've got to look to uh in addition
to making savings we've got to look to
find uh income from other sources
whether it's investment income or on uh
non-discretionary on discretionary
Services sorry non-sessionary services
that that we provide to residents
anyway that's um my comment and does
anyone else wish to have any further
contributions today councilman crawl
thank you chair
I mean this has been a very it's been
Cabinet member
the most difficult budget process we've
ever ever done but it's also been the
most informed budget process that I can
ever recall because at every stage we've
looked at the various scenarios we've
had a clear direction from corporate
resources and the team and I do Echo the
comments of congratulation to them
that we've actually been able to tell
how we're pulling this together and how
the money can be found and what the rest
of it and I don't like
chamber it's not necessary
yeah okay fine Council Barrett please is
this no comments this is this is this is
debate
yes it's a good
yes in that case could you do so
politely councilor Verity
Council Barrett please will you be quiet
or I'll have to suspend the meeting
yes please
foreign
right
um to those watching on YouTube sorry
about that um suspension but there was a
little bit of bother and I had to ask
um councilor Barrett to leave the
meeting
um for disruptive behavior we will now
continue members of the cabinet does
anyone else wish to comment councilman
crawl I hadn't actually completed
what I was saying
by the counselor that you asked to leave
the meeting councilor Simon Barrett I
think is important to point out the
accuracy there
so regardless of those statements we
prepared and we have been informed and
we have gone through a difficult budget
process and I've referred earlier on my
question to the uh potential deficits we
might face in the future
the one thing I've
taken from this budget process and
that's one thing I find it really
encouraging given that we're dealing
with a cost of living crisis where
everybody is very aware of inflation
rates of how much this is concerned how
much that is costing some things have an
effective inflation rate of 16 percent
uh We've recently had a 10.1 inflation
rate
the government hope it'll drop to about
five percent in the next few months but
the point I'm making here is that the
proposed increase that we can recommend
to council and why I'm happy to Second
this motion is still at the same level
I've just been for the last three or
four years it's about
three percent 2.99 to be precise and
it's about five pounds
um a year
a year five pounds Thirty ten pence a
week
that's pretty much the level we've had I
think we've recent years we've been
doing five pounds a year
a year difference is not dramatic and of
course at a rate of 2.99 it's nowhere
near any likely inflation rate for some
time to come and I think that's actually
quite an important point where
everything else is costing more
we are actually going to be costing
relatively less compared to inflation
the
net proportion of total council tax that
baber District Council
take if you like we we collect it but we
we don't get it majority goes to the
County Council a large portion goes to
the police and crime commissioner tiny
bit goes to the parish and town councils
our percentage has dropped in the time
I've been on this Council from 10 and
maybe a little over
to nine percent we're actually taking
less of the total council tax and
because we collected everybody sort of
points in our Direction I mean I know
the shared revenues partnership deal
with the realities of this situation but
we've actually reduced our costs and
kept Services as councilor Osborne
pointed out so I think we can commend
this budget to the council and ask them
for a positive vote
um on the basis that this is the most
responsible way of handling
general fund finances thank you
thank you councilman craw that's um very
good I agree with all of that does
anyone else councilman Tara
um as this is the first time I've sat in
this discussion as a Cabinet member I
just want to
say thank you to Melissa and her team
because actually I found it useful I
understood it which for me is probably a
hurdle but I just want to thank you for
all the hard work you've put into that
report it was excellent and I found it
very informative thank you
thank you anyone else councilor arthi
yeah at firstly I'd just like to say
that I I quite liked councilor Busby's
short introduction because it was much
shorter than we normally get for budget
presentations and
um
I think there's no need for it to be any
longer because we've been working on
these figures for three or four months
now so none of them come as any surprise
um I quite liked what he said about the
way that government funds local
authorities as well I can remember some
years back shortly after the
introduction of council tax and Forest
Heath did particularly well in in
Suffolk and it was because the way that
Government funding was distributed
happened to go in their favor he
mentioned the situation with mid-suffolk
and the situation that we find ourselves
in was we share staff and services their
position is much stronger than ours I
can only hope that in the years to come
at some point the the formula is reject
so that we end up being the ones that
are perhaps
um
given a little bit more Grant than
others it's just the way that it skews
and unfortunately it hasn't gone our way
for for quite a while
other than that I was I'm going to agree
with um well I wasn't I was going to say
it but then councilman cross said it
um about our take of the overall council
tax bill I think that's quite important
in a way um because even this year our
increase is lower than the increase of
the County Council and lower than the
increase of the police and crime
commissioner so our percentage of that
take is continuing to reduce so although
everybody knows that we collect it
the the amount of it that we actually
get to keep is reducing as a proportion
of the overall cash tax bill year on
year so we are less demanding than we
were in in a way
that's it
thank you councilor Arthur customer
problem
I would like to point to a contrast at
the increase proposed for the police and
crime commissioner this year will
lose a year
three times the size of ours
and you've got to remember that um with
that five pound Thirty increase per
annum faratas
um will be up to 182 pounds 64 for an
average bandee property which still
works out at only three pound fifty one
a week
pretty good what what we do
yeah let's just put a temper bit of put
some reality onto this it's
it's still one of I think it's one of
the highest in suffer unfortunately but
it's but it's still it's still good
value it's in the lower uh the fourth
quartile is still I think across gold
third quartile across the country
certainly
um when you look at all all district and
Borough councils it's um it's very
difficult doing comparisons yeah it is I
think we've got to be very careful we
need to look at doing things
12 months coming forward otherwise we
are not going to
be able to achieve the same kind of
Service delivery that we are at the
moment you can't keep having your costs
go up by an excess of 10 percent
and your income by only three percent
it's just the figures do not work out as
we've seen with the HRA which will come
unto in a minute
right okay if oh Council McLaren further
comment
um just uh
frustration that I think
Melissa put out at the parish liaison
meeting with the pound
I think that was really helpful and I
think we should adopt it to share with
our parishes I thought it was really
helpful to under to understand the split
of the council attacks thank you I agree
thanks
they're no further uh comments then we
can move the vote but before that I do
want to reiterate our thanks to Melissa
and her team her first budget that says
as section 151 officer
so thank you very much
we'll now move to the vote Jim I think
you should have given the cabinet member
for finance the opportunity to thank his
teammates
okay you have the last word council
Busby
and Well everybody's
[Laughter]
in fact I was keeping my powder dry
okay
until the council meeting
we'll move to that
okay
thank you chair that vote is now in
progress
Ive that is seven votes four and that's
unanimous thank you
moving on then item nine paper BCA 2240
the housing revenue account
2023-24 budget I'll now invite the
cabinet member for finance assets and
Investments to introduce the reports
councilor Busby
thank you
so the housing revenue account following
a period of five years that saw annual
one percent rent reductions which ended
in March 2020 the councils were allowed
to increase rent by the maximum of
silver price index plus one percent for
a period of five years from April 2020
so that means we're still in that
five-year period This has begun to
mitigate the impact of the one percent
reduction on the 30-year plan however
cost of living crisis has resulted in
the government making a change to this
rent settlement this is a significant
risk to the HRA as the recent reductions
and now the rent cap leaves the council
at risk of not being able to meet its
legal obligations
this is against the backdrop of Aging
stock which requires urgent investment
the latest forecast predicted an adverse
variance of 825 000 pounds against the
budgeted surface of 511. key factors in
this position are the additional costs
being incurred to address the backlog in
void and responsive repairs as well as
increasing material costs due to
inflation
the council's total cost of service has
increased by 3.67 million or 50 percent
whilst income has increased by 1.5
million or just eight percent
when setting the budget for the
forthcoming year the council must have
regard to the level of reserves needed
to provide enough resources to finance
estimated future expenditure plus any
appropriate allowances that should be
made for contingencies
reserves only provide one-off funding
so the council should avoid using
reserves to meet regular recurring
Financial commitments
searches against this backdrop that I
move the recommendations
we know that any increase in rents will
be burdensome particularly now but
unfortunately we are left with no choice
that's for a second though
thank you councilor both we may have a
second there
councilman clarem
okay members of the cabinet any
questions
Council McLaren thank you thank you
given the backdrop that you just talked
about councilor Busby and the cost of
living crisis
how as a council are we going to respond
to the anxiety
of
say the people in sheltered housing
and will that
increase the resource
by that I mean people in responding to
those anxieties
we
it won't help
but the situation the the increases that
we're talking about are significantly
less than the increases that are being
felt in the private sector
can I respond yeah no I understand that
I I what I'm thinking about is that
given the reductions you've had over the
previous years of course
the public don't actually save for that
they don't realize that's happening do
they so they're not ready for these uh
increases and I'm just wondering the
resources needed to cope with
people ringing and um yeah will that
have any do we have a
sort of an increase in resources
required to manage that because I think
a lot of people will be anxious
yeah it will it will in some respects
require additional resources we're
already recruiting Financial inclusion
officers to help
um but that's not just the only reason
the increase in rent will not result in
us having to recruit offices it's the
whole program of us
supporting our tenants through any
crisis cost of living crisis
and also it helps us prevent
homelessness as well we've got a
proactive program of working with our
tenants recognizing when they're likely
to get into rent arrears or if they're
already in rent arrears and hoping them
out of it so in answer to your question
um we're already got that program of
work with or without a rent increase we
will need additional offices already
recruiting to that
some of them will be as I've alluded to
earlier there will be government funded
but some of them will have to come out
of our of our own resources but in
regards to managing their expectations
and their anxiety we recently approved a
fantastic engagement policy which other
councils are taking on to use it's an
Exemplar example of a good engagement
policy and we will be out there talking
to our tenants I know the director of
housing has already had discussions with
the tenant panel about these proposed
increases and they they understand
they've had it explained to them they
understand what it's all about and
actually they're in agreement that we
need to do it so I hope that answers
your question
any other questions
councilor arthi
so question about
discussions that we've had over the last
three or four months
um whilst we've been putting all of this
together and I thought that we were
going to get some data on
um the private rented sector and the
increasing rents in the private rented
sector for comparison purposes I think
at the time we were looking at headlines
in the paper that said that the private
rental sector was looking at 10 or more
increases in some areas and I believe
somebody said we will go away and get
some data on that
comparison notices I just wondered if
that happened Council Oswald do you have
the answer yeah I thought you would
I've got some I don't know if it will be
sufficient for to answer Council Alfie's
question but yeah um the average in the
east of England privately rented is 875
pounds per month
um a range of there's a range of 715 to
1150 we are above the national average
which is 800 pounds per month in
comparison if you compare that to
affordable rent with the with the
increase it will be
um 625 pounds 53 per month on affordable
rent and on
um
on social rent
it will go from 422 pounds 77 to 452. so
if you compare 452 pounds 37 as an
average across the board against uh
um a private landlord average of 875
you're getting value for money there's
no doubt about it
chairman that wasn't actually
I'm sorry the only comparison that I was
looking at it's also the increase in the
private sector as a percentage because
we're talking about a percentage
increase
As I understood it
if the headlines in the papers are to be
believed the private rented sector in
some areas the increases over the last
12 months for the granting of the
attendances has been over 10 plus 10
percent and that's the data I thought we
were going to try and get
I'm kind of looking at Melissa but she's
not looking at me so
because I think I think it was Melissa
who said we will get that data
apologies that I will discuss with
Deborah and see what we can come back to
you on
sorry Miss Jim can I come in on that
Mr Jen
sorry yes you can so okay
um yeah I think yeah you did raise this
and you were concerned that with the the
market rate going up the formula for
affordable housing will also be going up
but what we do is it can be it's
calculated by a formula set at 80 of the
market rent or capped at the local
housing allowance and that's what we're
basing ours on the local housing
allowance does that answer your question
I don't know if Deborah's got any more
on that one
so the um so for private rented
accommodation in the 12 months to
December 20 20 22 it Rose by 4.2 percent
um that's can I come back that's not for
new tenancies though because I think
what was in the papers was
um it was not to do with the increase in
existing tenants were seeing in the
private sector
um it's it was the granting of new
tenancies in the private sector quite
simply on a supply and demand basis
because they were none available
um and I think that's what the articles
in the Press were about and that was the
granting of new Tendencies
where they were looking at an uplift of
10 over the previous tenancy when
somebody moved out
so so I can
um forward a chart on that which can be
included in the minutes if that helps
sorry Jim the reason for this is because
I mean we're looking at a high increase
this year and it's it's a high
percentage figure I know that there have
been years in the past where we've
actually reduced
um the council housing rent but that's
history
um and people are now staring at a
significant increase in in their rent
um I also think it's easy to say oh well
which it says in the report you know
there are lots of people who are on
benefits and so therefore it won't
affect them the same but there are also
people in our houses that aren't on
benefits that are suffering
um at the moment paying their bills and
a large increase is is not welcome
um so I I think it's kind of idea
explain that things are not easy out
there so you know we've got all the
issues as
um I think councilor Busby said I think
with financing the improvement in our
stock
increasing our stock as well which is
another one of our Ambitions but I think
it's also useful to actually explain
what things are like out in the market
so yes there's a significant increase
coming but you know just be aware of the
fact that out there in the market
things are not Rosy either and the
private sector is looking at you know
new tenancies being over 10 higher than
they were 12 months ago
yeah that's um just before I go to today
that's true and I think having that
information in in the minutes would be
very helpful just to set it all in in
the context of what's going on the
private section and also we know
um that the private sector are facing
huge increases in in costs for for
retrofitting which um some of them are
finding almost impossible to uh to Bear
but uh Deborah if you had anything
further
thank you and and also just to give some
context so so
um the council took on approximately 80
million pounds um debt with the
refinancing settlement and at the time
it was the understanding of all local
authorities that there would be a rent
settlement
um which would enable us to update our
properties and keep our properties in a
good standard of repair of course that
hasn't happened and we've had a
significant rent decrease over the last
few years and and
um you know we're here discussing today
that you know the rent increase which
isn't going up again
um with the rate of inflation although
you know times are really hard out there
for our tenants we also have to think
about that we have a responsibility to
provide housing which is safe and warm
and dry and we've got a real real
challenge
um
you know over the next 30 years because
we need to pump a substantial amount of
capital into our properties just to keep
them up to a reasonable standard and
um
you know as I've said that that that's a
real Challenge and if we don't increase
the rent the rents I'm just not sure how
I'm gonna sit and present to members
that were able to to do that going
forward
counselor party is that the end of your
questions okay next question any other
questions councilman crawl it's really
more of an observation arising out of
councilor arthi's um observation
um
it's also true that this is a developing
situation because a lot of private
rental market properties are about to
come towards the end of a mortgage
period which they're now going to have
to go out and look for the mortgage they
can get
those mortgage rates have yet
level they've been for very many years
and and for those people who have got
the same thing where they have to renew
their mortgage at the end of the two or
three or four or five year period
it's going to be a huge increase that
will be passed on to the private renters
and
um so whatever figure we arrive at now
is not going to be the figure that will
actually apply it will almost certainly
be a great deal higher and I would have
said 10 percent is probably under
EST the sort of levels that some private
landlords may need to apply
thank you for that
if there are no other questions oh
councilor Osborne
well I just want to finish off questions
first I'll go to other members and I'll
come back
okay
I think
it's laughing and other councilors have
said here today I think demonstrates the
challenges the huge challenges that the
housing team have got ahead of them over
the next few months over the year and
Beyond and just set it as an example if
we didn't increase the rent
the shortfall would be I think it is in
no no increase by a reduction in income
by year 30 would be 58 nearly 58 and a
half thousand
so which is a huge amount to lose on
that in regards to
um in regards to the delivery of
services and as as the housing director
of housing has already alluded to we've
got so many things that we need to do we
want to be able to do it all but we
won't definitely without the increase
and I think it's fair to say that our
tenants do appreciate they do understand
where we're coming from and that was
shown by the conversations that Deborah
has had with the tenants panel but
that's no excuse we can still get out
there as counselors we can do it in our
district councilors report at our Parish
Town meetings we can talk to our
residents we can get out there walk up
on the streets and talk to them if we
you know get them to under help them to
understand the situation as well but we
don't must underestimate their
intelligence they they know where we're
coming from they know why we've got to
do it but yeah there will be anxieties
out there and we need to meet those
challenges
thank you Mr Jim thank you Council
Osborne
um councilor Hinton do you have any
questions
just a quick one uh to say that I hope
that the forthcoming decisions list
cab2393
um strategic review of garage sites and
baber District Council is going to
happen in March because it's a little
bit ambiguous when you look at 4.22 and
it talks about uh we're currently
receiving around 40 inquiries per month
garages can be hard to let in some areas
well
there's a balancing act to be done there
somewhere to make sure that we're
getting garages lit the people who are
going to bring in some income because
the amount that comes into the council
is is quite considerable from
non-housing
non-dwelling income
it's going up from 183 to 238 000 55 000
increase so there's a potential for some
more there if we can't earn it from
garages perhaps we should be turning
them into houses
because I know there are a lot of
garages out there where they are
leasehold sites with rather decrepit
asbestos based garages sitting on them
which the people who hold the lease
can't afford to remove because of all
the regulations on asbestos Etc and so
they just gradually deteriorating into
isols and perhaps we've got to sort of
come up with some sort of compromise
there that's the same thing you're
preaching to convert I think all of us
would agree with that so uh but Deborah
you want to come back on
thank you we we are aware that there is
work to do on garages especially letting
them and we have um wait wait we're
hoping to we to we recruit to a new Post
in April and we've got a new process so
members will see a significant increase
in our income from garages and when
we've carried out that exercise we will
then understand where our difficult to
let garages are and then we can start
the process of understanding whether
there is any mileage in developing on
those sites
thank you Deborah
um I'm now moving back to the cabinet
for debate so I've got a three hands the
councilman VC Busby and then Osborne I
think we're in that order
oh okay
now okay quickly if you wanted to just
say something out and then yeah also
there has been a lot a lot of work over
the last couple of years actually
looking at garage sites for potential
development and strangely enough they
set up a traffic light system there will
be a report coming I don't know if it
will be in this Administration now it
will most probably be after the
elections but there is a report coming
forward I think out of all the sites
that we've looked at I think there was
about a total of three that had
potential for development and that was
that was it mainly due to the mixed
tenure that you've got on a lot of these
sites it would be impossible to pull
some down when you've got some that are
owner occupier so yeah there has been an
extensive piece of work on that but it's
interesting to see that about three
sites get the green light for future
development but just to reassure you
um there has been a great deal of work
going in on the lettings of it as as
Deborah's alluded to but also on the
potential development of those sites as
well thank you Mr Chen thank you oh
Castle bus we going yeah
look every year we talk about get
reusing garages and building on them
let's draw a line under it it probably
isn't going to happen anytime soon
we can't
as Jan said there's so few baber growth
have looked at this obviously because
we're targeted with building houses
we've looked at this as an obvious sort
of land to do it the problem is it's not
just mixed tenure it's also the fact
that most of these sites
where there are other garages to rent
there are parking problems
so if we build more houses it will
create even more parking problems we'd
probably be better off turning them into
car parks you know it's it seems like an
obvious win but I don't think it's going
to generate anything
big soon
because it doesn't have to be houses
they could be redeveloped into garages
that could be let at a reasonable rent
rather than the one pound a year or
whatever it is that they're paying
leasehold at the moment to
Factory contribute to an ISO I think
well thanks for that we'll move on from
garages now I think
um
[Laughter]
did you have
um okay go on yeah
um what concerns me
images are
by definition old
um and we're trying to look at how to
improve them and if they are old and
somebody mentioned asbestos
then
surely we as a council have a duty of
care to ensure that any asbestos in any
of those buildings is removed because if
the building's deteriorate the asbestos
will deteriorate and the people will
suffer
that's all FairPoint and I think we our
our work on asbestos will continue and
and um as and when it's identified like
that councilman crawl it's only
appointed the information it's just that
that beat out all asbestos as though it
is equal and it is definitely not an
equal the fundamental form of
asbestos found in every Farm in the
country is chrysatile what is called
gray Asbestos and it's a fibrous
compound
um where asbestos fibers in a very small
percentage are bonded with cement it
forms a needle-like fiber which is not
the sort that causes mesothelioma that
would be the
insulation types of asbestos like blue
and White those are the Dangerous Ones
because they have a hook shaped fiber so
we must be careful
um the actual problem of um chrysatile
in is if you actually break it up you
actually create a problem where none
needs to exist
um because the one thing with Crystal
tile is you don't take power tools to
its uh rotary Grinders or anything like
that so in the science side of things
not all asbestos is equal but
unfortunately the law treats it as so
and in fact I have to say in this
instance the law was poorly framed
thank you we should not panic is what
I'm trying to say
um all that curvy Roofing okay Chrissa
tile yes
every Farm in the country okay right
um we are into debate does anyone else
wish to make any comment um
it doesn't involve garages or parking
if customers we
yeah I think just to emphasize what
they're saying about the the costs going
forward look we know we've got a hell of
a lot of work to do to bring our houses
up to date and she's not just to bring
them to a current standard standards are
changing all the time we've got to
improve the Energy Efficiency of the
housing
where does the money come from that well
it has to come from uh from rental
income Etc
the problem we face and that what I try
to get across in my introduction was
that
the government
chop and change the rules on a regular
basis but having made the rules then
they'll stick to them
now we were supposed to be in the middle
of a five-year
agreement where the rentals increased by
Cube Consumer Price Index plus one
percent this is to recoup the five years
where they're reduced well they've
changed that because they didn't like
the outcome of that they've changed it
how on Earth can you plan a
multi-million pound
operation which is what it is
when the ground rules keep changing
we've got to get a better way of doing
it
or the governments are going to get a
better way of doing it
councilor Osborne
he's like this is a
good to it and thank you those officers
for that working into it however as I
said about the general budget the same
applies to the HRA the housing revenue
account budget there's huge challenges
ahead and whatever the government do or
don't do we've got to make sure we're
ahead of the game and that we're we've
got a an HRA budget that enables us to
deliver what our residents want
um within reason of course
but also to be able to make sure that
we're compliant to make sure that we're
reaching that EPC standard C at least I
think we've got between a and C we've
got 68 of our stock already reached that
but then the other stock that we've got
you've got these 60 70 homes that were
built in the 60s or 70s
that have got need huge investment into
them and so there's some real challenges
ahead for officers to make sure that the
we did let's continue to deliver on the
HRA account but at the moment it's it's
it's a good budget but there are
challenges ahead for officers but thank
you very much I don't mean to steal your
thunder councilor Busby but
it is my housing team so I do want to
thank them
and the finance officers for the
brilliant work they've put into to get
where we have with this HRA thank you Mr
chairman thank you Council Osborne
and anything else from anyone
anything else
right then I think we moved to the road
can we stop the vote please
thank you chair the vote is now in
progress
thank you chair that is seven votes for
that's unanimous
thank you next item item 10 paper BCA
2241 business rates relief policies and
again I'll now invite the cabinet member
for finance assets and Investments to
introduce this report councilor Busby
who does all the work can't you I mean
anybody else like to thank my team
before I start the introduction
ah yeah
well for my third and final report today
business rates the government recently
announced two new relief policies as
part of the Autumn statement they are a
business rates retail hospitality and
Leisure relief scheme and they love
their Snappy titles don't they which
will increase the relief level of relief
to those covered by the policy from the
current level of 50 to 75 for the year
23 24. this is up to a maximum of a
hundred and ten thousand pounds for
business not to per Outlet
and a new supporting small business
release scheme which will cap business
rate increases to 600 pounds per year
from the start of 23 24 year for those
businesses that are losing eligibility
or seeing reductions in small business
rate relief or rural rate relief
we will use our discretionary relief
powers to apply these savings and the
government will then fully compensate us
for the total amount of Revenue lost
through making these grants so these
reliefs cost us nothing
obviously a local business rate payers
and the local economy will benefit
these reliefs need to be applied to
bills that are going out in early March
hence the urgency to approve today these
schemes
these discretionary policies are based
on the criteria outlined in the
government guidance but if members have
any questions
I'm pleased to delegate
answering them to Andrew Wilcock the SRP
operations manager
I am relieved to move the recommendation
set out in section three and would ask
for a second thank you thank you
councilor Busby councilor Osborne you
second
any questions members of the cabinet
councilor McCraw first and then Council
rathi I have a strong suspicion that Mr
Andrew is expecting this question
because I want to clarify something so
as I understand it uh the businesses
that are eligible for the rhl scheme
retail hospitality and Leisure have a
rateable value that rateable value
normally has a multiplier the multiplier
is often 0.5 50 and I'm assuming that
that is still in place
is it correct then that a business in
this sector that currently has that
multiplier of 0.5 therefore fifty
percent will be automatically increased
to 0.75 thus paying half the previous
um business rate till non-domestic rate
could I have confirmation of that
Andrew do you have an answer of that
yeah thank you chair the multiplier has
been frozen but we will automatically
raise the relief to the 75 and Bill
everybody accordingly so the net effect
would be that that this business rate
would effectively halve in that instance
thank you
Council rathi
yeah my question is about Village Halls
um and I asked it before and I can't
remember I don't think there was a full
answer Village Halls have historically
benefited from I think 90 relief but
they've had to pay the tax
does this affect Village halls in any
way and if it does does it mean that
they don't have to pay that remaining 10
percent remaining 10 is a lower figure
foreign
[Music]
we will cover that with the retail
relief
can I ask another one yes um will that
automatically be applied because we know
who they are because we know what
they've been benefiting from in the past
or will it be by application
so those that are currently receiving
the release it will automatically be
applied and there's just under 500 and
obviously we'll do publicity to pick up
any new cases and I think Village Halls
have currently got the simply so on the
retail side
thank you
any other questions
councilor McLaren
well I'm going to add
to show my ignorance about
I don't know I'm going to say it
properly hereditamins
um I had to I have to confession I had
to go to the dictionary to find out what
actually that meant so read it with
interest when I found out what it meant
but what I didn't understand was the
charity shop biting that because
according to the dictionary that's any
property that may pass to an air what I
didn't understand why the charity shops
were in there
thank you Jim so heroditamins is
the rating terminology for media on
street we would call it properties
um so
um yeah it does include any building
that charity shops are in
um so we will can't relief in that
aspect so really it's about the who owns
the property at the charity shop
probably is renting from is that is that
the link or yeah they will have a lease
but I mean heroism is just really the
term that is used to identify what
you and I would call a property okay
very much thank you so it's slightly
different from your dictionary
definition perhaps yeah yeah
okay
um if there are no questions further
questions from the cabinet counselor
Hinton any questions from you yes just a
quick excuse me just a quick question uh
in the past public toilets have been
liable for business rates
what about car parks and public toilets
are they come under the small business
part or I don't suppose they come under
the hospitality side but yeah
um pardon the pun but there is a
government relief for public toilets
which came in a few years ago so those
that we have will receive that relief
car parks are rated
um so the charge is due it wouldn't come
under retail Hospitality they are it's
excluded from that
so presumably then they won't qualify
for this 100 one because they're already
getting a relief from a different source
the toilet sorry
okay
right uh forgot to pay yeah
moving back uh we're into debate does
anyone wish to contribute to the debate
on this paper any comments anyone wishes
to make
in which case then we're all happy to go
straight to the vote
coming up the vote please thank you
[Music]
that is seven votes four that is
unanimous
because I just go ahead thank my team
for Sterling
to put in the Dream Team
three of them sitting there was it
um I see no evil anyway thank you team
it's been brilliant
if you cancel the Busby moving on to the
last item then pay for BCA 2242
consultation of the revised table
Affairs for Hackney carriages and I'd
now like to invite the cabinet member
for an environment to introduce the
report councilor malvisi
thank you chair
um the paper you have before you
um is was presented to Licensing and
Regulatory and they have agreed
um approved it
so after Consulting with the um the
trade it was agreed to amend the Hackney
tariff by removing
um by moving from
yards
to Miles and a tenth of a mile
it was also agreed that tariff 4 would
show as an extra because of the size of
vehicles used the time of day these
vehicles are used and the usage over 365
days
um
I asked cabinet to approve
the recommendation at 3.1
thank you thank you councilman VC may I
have a second of these
second though Council rathi
any any questions
from members of the cabinet councilman
mccrawal are there separate votes to be
taken on 3.2 3 and 4.
3.1 is in three sections but those three
sections form 3.1
so you're voting for 3.1
but we have offered you 3.2
a recommendation from licensing is to go
for 3.1
um I'm not quite certain as to this as
whether 3.1 3.2 3.3
we're trying to sort this out and thanks
for pointing it out I think
important to get this sorted
I mean surely we've already done 3.3
and 3.4 is a reason for the decision so
presumably it's one or the other
I think it's 3.1 3.2 and I'm not quite
certain as to whether we have just 3.1
changes the Tariff
right obviously 3.2 is is is actually a
different recommendation
of it yes and and uh the
preferred one
3.2 just lists the various options but
it says the option two
um the increase of the first Mile in
each one tenth is is the preferred so
we're excuse me
single vote for 3.1 plus 3.2 option 2.
can I um
yes
that's the last
it doesn't seem as 3.2 is compatible
with 3.1 but can I can I say okay can
can you clarify this for us please
yes thank you um yes so option if for
clarity option two
um of the Tariff is what the Hackney
Carriage Trade preferred and that is a
4.8 of the report
in relation to the recommendations it is
the recommendation is for committed to
consider opting for option two
um which is what the Hackney Carriage
Association agreed on
so
um for clarity what what is paragraph
3.1 in the report and so the apologies
Neil Gardner isn't here the author of a
report but just to clarify um
the first option for committee at the
licensing sorry licensing a regulatory
committee is actually 3.1 that is is the
the option that we're looking at
I think the important thing is
whether the recommendation that we
approve because we're making the
decision whether it is consistent with
the Licensing and Regulatory committees
View and it is isn't it
that's correct yes the licensing
regulatory committee recommended option
two for the committee to consider yeah
okay thank you
[Music]
I'm still uncertain yeah I feel
uncertain as to what purpose option 3.2
serves
sorry if I could Mark yeah yeah
um yes 3.2 was capturing the fact that
it had been to the Licensing and
Regulatory committee but I don't believe
that should have really been there as a
recommendation it should have been there
for for note 3.1 option two within 3.1
is the preference from committee but
also
3.11 and 3.13 or additional
um
found part of the option but they're two
different different recommendations that
are coming forward that not relating to
the Tariff choice that was chosen so
3.11 is regularizing Miles get and one
tenth of a mile replacing yards
at 3.13 is that tariff 4 is shown as an
extra due to the size of vehicles time
of day usage over 365 days of the year
so they're two additional notes it's
3.12 that is the recommendation of the
Licensing and Regulatory committee that
they would like you to accept and that
includes the um uh increase the first
mile plus tense it does yes right so
fundamentally chair 3.2 as a
recommendation appears completely
redundant and possibly shouldn't have
been included in the room correct yes I
have to say given the difficulties we've
had with the Hackney fares and Licensing
in general that's really unfortunate but
I think it's absolutely essential we
make it clear that it's unnecessary for
us to vote on
yes absolutely but it's for information
it's for information it's not a
recommendation and and would be um it's
best place to be in the body of the
report rather than recommendation
section yeah
um I agree okay so we're all clear on
that now
questions
any questions apart from
okay um councilor Hinton do you have a
question
just a quick one Mr chairman I know you
probably feel the same as a representing
a ward that's butted up to that uh Iron
Curtain called the ethics Suffolk border
um but why have we got breckland
Kingsland Norwich and all the rest of it
in rates in this chart and nothing from
Colchester which is That's rated on our
doorstep on 10 drinks are on our
doorstep
um what are their rates are they higher
than ours lower than ours what
I must admit that that's uh that's
interesting yeah and uh it would be very
useful to have some comparisons with our
immediate neighbors as well as um for
the food but if there's any explanation
for that okay uh you know yes there is
um after there is a chart out of 350
councils and the private home monthly is
a body that registers where we sit
within other Council areas and for we
are placed if this is to be approved we
will be placed um at 154 out of 350 and
East Suffolk is 13th of how much they
charge so they're quite a lot higher
West Suffolk is 121 Ipswich is 218 so we
would be placed in
but do we know what Colchester or
Braintree or tendering
that would be very helpful actually just
for comparison
um
while Kate's looking for that does
anyone else have
any further questions we'll move into
debate in a minute then
sorry so um Colchester is 158 so we
would be above Colchester we would
charge more than Colchester currently do
what about 10 do you have tendering
the other point to make is just that
looking these rates up live like this is
obviously prior to any of those
authorities making their changes which
they might be making in their budget
books but I think it's absolutely Fair
comment that we could include other
neighboring authorities in our
benchmarking
um when we take this you know forward
next time that we do this obviously the
trade's been consulted on this so
they're supportive of this change as
well thanks Mark
uh we do sorry tendering um we if you
were to approve this we would be above
tendering right thank you very much
thank you
um right uh we'll now move into debate
marks made a
very useful point of reminder and it's
one that um I want to pick up on it does
seem that this
um does have the overwhelming support of
the trade and I know we've had issues in
the past with
um getting trade buy into changes like
this but I think this time we've got
that from the trade so um uh that gives
us confidence that what we've got in
front of us is is right and will be
acceptable any any comments from anyone
else
nope well in which case then we can move
to the vote
thank you chair that vote is now in
progress and we are only voting for
recommendation 3.1
thank you chair that is seven votes four
and that is unanimous
close of the meeting thank you very much
everyone uh our next meeting Monday 6th
of March at 2PM thank you